نعم سفيان في الحقيقه المظاهره متواصله
كما قلت غضب كبير يرافقها من قبل
المشاركين هنا سواء من الجاليه الكرديه او
من بقيه المشاركين بعض
المواجهات والمشاحنات بدات على هامشي هذه
المظاهره هنا في ساحه الجمهوريه تحديدا في
احد الشوارع القريبه حيث يحاول الشرطه
ولكن ايضا المنظمون لهذه المظاهرات تهدئه
الاوضاع ووقف هذه المناوشات والمواجهات
المحدوده التي اندلعت منذ قليل كما قلت
حسب ما شاهدناه كان هناك شخص دخل في
المظاهره يبدو انه تفوقها بما فيهما على
انها عبارات عنصريه ما بلغنا الان فسبب
ذلك من مزيدا من الاحتقان والغضب اندلعت
بعضه بعض المشاحنات حتى الموجات التي
استخدم خلالها المحتجون
مفرقعات كما قالوا بتشيل بعض هات الاشاريه
وغيرها هنا في شارع قريب من ساحه
الجمهوريه وسط العاصمه الفرنسيه همم باريس
في الحقيقه غضب كبير لمستناه منذ صباح
اليوم هنا في ساحه الجمهوريه لدى الجاريه
الكرديه التي تقول ان السلطات الفرنسيه هي
في الحقيقه مسؤوله عن حمايتها يقول
المسؤولون الاكراد المحليون هنا في فرنسا
انهم طلبوا من وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه عن
تزيد وتعزز حمايتهم خلال هذه الفتره ولكن
ذلك لم يحصل على حد تعبيرهم وهو ما يفسر
هذا الغضب الذي نلمسه اليوم يقولون ان
الهجوم هو الهجوم ارهابي وهجوم عنصريه
ايضا استهدفهم هنا وسط العاصمه باريس همم
الغاز للدموع في ساحه الجمهوريه كما نرى
الغاز الدموع
وسط همم الساحه هنا في وسط العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس كما نلاحظ ان المشاركين
يتحركون في اتجاه عكسي همم الشارع الذي
توجد فيه المواجهات هناك قرب ساحه
الجمهوريه
وفتحت الى وسط العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
الموسم للدموع قويه الان هنا في ساحه
الجمهوريه وسط العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
ولكن مع ذلك ما زالت هذه المظاهره متواصله
هنا في ساحه الجمهوريه نعم سوريا طبعا
مباشره من العاصمه باريس وشات هؤلاء
الشباب الشباب
[موسيقى]
الى دوافع سياسيه تقف وراء ما حصل هذه
الحادثه والمقتل
همم اعتراض امس ندعم هذه الجزئيه وهذه
الدوافع
في المظاهره واغلب الذين اخذوا الكلمه هنا
خلفي في هذه المظاهره ان دوافع سياسيه تقف
وراءها هذا الهجوم بعضهم يتهم جهات تركيا
على حد تعبير المحتاجين هنا وايضا على حد
تعبير
الاكراد والناشطين الاكراد في فرنسا وفي
كل مكان على حد تعبيرهم لا ادري سفيان
تشاهد والمشاهدين والمشاهدون يرون صوره
عبد الله وجلال القائد الكردي همم هنا وسط
مساحه الجمهوريه هي همم الساحه هذه
الساحه وهذا يترافق مع بعض الاتهامات
للتركيا بانها لديها يد او ايادي في هذا
الهجوم الذي استهدف الكرديه هنا في باريس
وفقه ما يقول المسؤولون الاكراد هنا في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس لهذا وهم غاضبون
من السلطات الفرنسيه التي يعتبرون انها لم
تحميهم كما كان يلزم ولم تتفاعل ايجابا مع
طلباتهم لمزيد حمايتهم ولتعزيز حمايتهم
خصوصا وان هذه الفتره هي فتره حساسه
بالنسبه لهم وهي تتزامن مع ذكر قتل ثلاثه
ناشطين اكراد وسط العاصمه الفارسيه باريس
منذ سنوات هنا في فرنسا
الفرنسيه وهذا ما يفسر المواجهات سواء
التي اندلعت الان على هامشي هذا التجمع
وعلى هامشي هذه المظاهره هنا في ساحه
الجمهوريه